all they got to do is work on your evil
laugh and we can be good friends
I wished we could have played more with
what was quite obvious to a lot of us
was the relationship between Stevie and
Alex
Russo famously played by Selena Gomez
came
sex Romance
Wizards of Waverly Place yeah to a whole
generation cell will always be the
Disney channel's Teenage sorceress she's
the rebel of the family while Alex Found
Love interests in Mason and Dean I know
it was a real catch wasn't I she almost
had a romance with Stevie nickels Haley
kyoko's character I'll race to there
this according to Peter Marietta the
showrunner on Wizards for its first
three seasons what is a storyline you'd
like to have explored easy easy easy he
tells the story on Wizards of Waverly
pod a re-watch podcast hosted by
Selena's former co-stars Jennifer Stone
and David DeLuise
I wished we could have played more with
what was quite obvious to a lot of us
was the relationship between Stevie and
Alex right right but we weren't yeah we
weren't able to in that time but it was
pretty clear to all of us what that
relationship was yeah
and that would have been fun
[Music]
for some context season three of the
series started in 2009. fast forward to
2023 and the group admits the Disney
channel is now more inclusive they were
just a few years down the line we maybe
could have played with that but yeah
nowadays that could happen yeah they did
it I mean Disney channel has had
characters and they did it at that time
it wasn't a thing no we couldn't tell
but we got as close as we could to I
mean it was pretty close yes but it was
pretty right there it was pretty much I
love that answer that would have been
great that would have been great I would
love to do magic it's kind of I feel
like I'm disappointing the kids in a way
because they ask us how to do it I'm
like oh it's all fake it's all green
screen and of course after four seasons
and over a hundred episodes Selena went
on to make magic elsewhere singing
[Music]
acting in movies are you being serious
and more acting on TV is this really
happening again well you know who are we
without a homicide I think my advice is
to not be afraid as sell explained to
E.T years after hanging up her wand she
still remembers feeling sad about saying
goodbye to Alex Russo when Wizards ended
you know I I felt like I was leaving
behind a huge part of who I was and
growing up so it was
it's bittersweet also Bittersweet
thinking of Alex's teenage romance with
Stevie that could have blossomed
foreign